hi everyone it's me danny ceo and
welcome to a delicious edition of do
just one thing
[Music]
hi everyone it's me danny seo and
welcome to a delicious edition of do
just one thing and today we're gonna
make homemade pizza dough why buy it
when you can diy it and yes you really
can do this with two simple ingredients
and what you need
self-rising flour you can find this at
any supermarket it's very easy to find
it says self-rising flour right on it
it's flour with a little bit of salt and
baking powder all in one if you can't
find it
you don't have to tweet me all you have
to do is add about a teaspoon of baking
powder to make this a three
ingredient pizza dough recipe and the
other thing is a little unusual greek
yogurt this is the amazing secret
ingredient that transforms the
self-rising flour into the world's best
pizza dough what we're gonna do is put
two cups
of self-rising flour and what i was
taught
by a very well-known baker is to always
spoon
your flour into your measuring cup you
get a more precise measurement which you
don't really have to do for this recipe
because this is also
a very forgiving pizza dough recipe
and then for our yogurt we're doing one
part of this this is our liquid
and what i love about this is that it's
also full of calcium
there's protein in this
and yes while there is
probiotics in yogurt
don't think this is going to be a
probiotic rich pizza dough recipe
because once you bake it the probiotics
die which is why yogurt has to be
refrigerated so we're just going to dump
this into the bowl
it doesn't need to rest
it doesn't need any yeast
it doesn't need any special ingredients
i'm using a spoon
to mix it guys
in a bowl
and you just start incorporating
the dough
together
okay so right now if you look at it it's
kind of flaky
just take your hands
start kneading it together and what
you'll see is that it starts to become a
really great dough
this takes about what was it a minute
two minutes
to make this dough
[Music]
you can see this now we have some dough
and i did make one a little earlier
and to roll it out i just take a little
more of that self-rising flour
i put it on here
and you can use the palms of your hands
to kind of stretch it out
if you want to use a rolling pin you can
or a wine bottle
which is great too
just going to use some of the flour to
clean my hands too and then you dress it
however you want so you can take a
little bit of sauce
and this is no frills guys you just dump
it on
shake it around
take a little bit of cheese throw it on
top it doesn't need to be precious add
whatever you want
and
you know i made one earlier right
so right in the air fryer
six minutes
it's going to show you what beautiful
pizza looks like
and we have a crispy crunchy
cheesy
delicious
two ingredients
pizza dough with sauce
cheese veggies the best part the crispy
cheese on the side
by the way if you're making this pizza
dough recipe please be sure to tag us at
the drew barrymore show on your social
media accounts and check out the
drewberrymareshow.com for more recipes
and ideas and don't forget
to pick up my magazine
naturally danny ceo where it's full of
recipes just like this so you can get
your healthy delicious fast and easy
onto
[Music]
you